this is a production of cornell
university
thank you
it's a it's a pleasure to be here i'm
very glad to share
the things i've been researching and
i've been learning this past few years
about polyploids with you guys
and today we are going to discuss these
models
uh how to apply this genetic models in
in this polyploid species
and uh
first i would just like to
oops here
just to justify why i'm working with
polyploids
and that polyploids are basically in
organisms with multiple multiple copies
of a complete set of chromosomes
and uh of course we are diploids we have
two copies polyploids have multiple
copies here we have an example of oak
banana three copies
uh
blackberry and blueberry and
potato and uh
rose
this is miscon this is um
panicum and this is uh they have four
copies we have six copies in
chrysanthemum and sweet potato and just
god knows who knows how many cubs we
have in in sugar cane sugarcane is a
mess
but the thing is
uh
uh this
these multiple copies
they impose a lot of challenges to
genomic analysis because instead of just
having two allele segregating you have
multiple alleles segregated
and of course this affects the practical
breeding
and uh
just
uh
right off the bat i'm showing you what
is our objective here in our group in nc
state
we want to develop computational tools
to the whole
pipeline data analysis for polyploids
since the raw sequence dnas
to the breeding uh situations right so
we need to to go through all these
stages here
um
so we need to from the raw dna we need
markers we need the linkage map and i'll
show you why we need the linkage map in
this presentation
we will connect this linkage map with
phenotypes and have the qtl we can use
this in selection and try to design
better breeding strategies
and we have so far two programs that we
are extending for our more complex
polyploid populations
basically we have met poly and qtl poly
there are two programs
one for building linkage maps and the
other one for mapping qtls but
thinking in in in
building maps in a more broad sense we
are not just ordering markers we are
actually trace back the inheritance of
the haplotypes of these
uh polyploids and and i'm going to show
you this in in detail
today
and
in the next phase of this this research
we want to implement this software which
we call ggs poly which means genetic and
genomic selection poly
for polyploids so we are going to use
all the structure of inheritance of
haplotypes and these genetic
informations to try to help breeders uh
making long and short-term decisions in
their breeding progress but and we are
going to talk this
in this seminar
so just an overview of polyploid species
so here we have our deployed species
right just two copies of the genome
but we can have two types of polyploid
species actually more than two but let's
let's stay just with two species two
types
uh here we have an auto tetraploid or an
auto polyploid when you have multiple
sets from the same origin right and
here's an example potato we have four
sets right in a tetraploid and here we
have a fish
uh slide
for this
potato
and we can have aloe tetraploids are
allo polyploids where we have multiple
sets
of the different origins and here we
have an example of the aloe x applied
wheat here you can see we have three
genomes and they are uh
they behave much uh
more like a deployed genome in terms of
segregation
the problem here is when you have an
auto polyploid
meiotic instant instance
so the meiosis of an auto polyploid is
quite complex and here i'm showing you
the the meiotic pairing of an auto
tetraploid so you have four three
options here
you can have
two of these homologues pairing two by
two we call it by valence
uh you can have this all four
homologues pairing
all at once we call this tetravalent
uh and here you have three pairing
by themselves and we have one
uh
isolated uh chromosome
so these are trivalent in a and one
so this case here usually they they
yield uh
sterile progenies so we don't care too
much about this in this context but
these two they're quite common
and you're going to see how to to use
this
but uh and here just some examples of uh
some slides of
meiotic
cells in sweet potato here as you can
see we have an extra valence so all
chromosomes are are combining here and
they can exchange arms in all these
places that they are are paired so here
we have another one here we have a
tetravalent and so on and here we have
a
several bivalents
and and here is just some meiosis of a
sugarcane
we can have several by valence in a
sugarcane but this is as you can see
it's quite
crowded and quite complex uh
and
i think this is the most
important thing to to understand about
polyploids is the segregation patterns
that these complex genomes can have
so in a diploid let's imagine an
outcrossing species where you have
four alleles right in a deployed it's
very simple you can combine a gamete
with a a1 a2 or a1 or a2 we have two
possible gametes and here a3 and 4 and
if you combine you have four possible
genotypes this is very simple and of
course here we have three possible
genotypes if you have a biolic marker
and if you have a biolytic marker you
can't distinguish between big a and
small a so these two guys here they are
the same in this situation
in tetraploids we have six possible
uh
six possible gametes and this i'm not
considering something we call double
reduction where the same allele can be
present in the gametes so here we have
if we consider the mojito reduction we
have classes like a1 a1 and i'm not
considering this here okay
so we have six possible gametes in one
parent six possible gametes in the other
parent and you have 36 possible gametes
right
and here if you assess this information
using a biolic marker
some of these
gametes here you can't distinguish them
right because you just have two alleles
and you have some combinations of these
uh genotypes here and in this case if
you have a biolic marker with two doses
we call those is the number of the the
the
alternator the the
each one of the alleles here or the
reference allele uh it doesn't matter uh
but in this case let's call this two
dose alleles
this will be the segregation it will be
1 2 8 to 18 to 8 to 1 right
and this is for a tetraploid and this is
for an extra point right exaploid we
have
20 possible
gametes for one parent 20 possible
gametes for the other parents and when
you combine we have 400 possible gametes
the same thing we have if you have three
doses here we can have a segregation
like 1 218 299 to
164 to 99 to 18 to 1. so as you can see
this is a very complex scenario when you
compare with the deployed scenario right
so
how to deal with this right and the
first question is how to assess this
information right
and in deploys we are very used to
of course to to to genotype
using
gbs right
uh this is the the
the genotype of choice nowadays so
in a diploid it's very easy to
separate between
the homozygous and the two classes and
the heterozygous you just have three
classes here right
and this is like
how this data would look like in a real
situation
but in a tetraploid
so if you think in that segregation one
two eight to eighteen to eight to one we
have this type of scenario
and as you can see it's much difficult
to
draw
the the limitation between these clouds
here right
and this in the next support is even
worse
because
you have classes like one
in classes like 164. so how can it
distinguish between all these these
classes in this scenario right
so
back in 2012
we proposed the model uh since 2012
there's a lot of software to do this
but in our case we use a bayesian
approach approach to do this and this is
a real data for sweet potato and what we
do here we use both the segregation in a
population and also
the ratio between the two variants
and uh
we use this in a combined way in a in a
in a vision network we maximize this
visual network
and then what we can do is to classify
each one of these individuals here right
and
here you can see you have the two
parents
with this triangle in this square in the
middle probably there are three doses
right uh of course the model takes into
account this
and then you have the segregation you
can
classify each one of these individuals
but
but but much more than that
you can
attribute some probability for this
individual so
usually individuals that falls
a fall between clouds you are not so
certain about the genotypes of the
individuals so what you can have are
these probability distributions for each
one of its individuals right and we are
just expressing these probabilities in
this three-dimensional graph here and
this is just one snip this is real data
but we have this for all snips in our
population and i'm going to show
the population in a second right
but this is important to know how we
assess the genetic variation in such a
complex species nowadays what we are
trying to do
uh actually working with more we are
trying to instead of just using these
dosages we are trying to use the
haplotypes
combining multiple values
uh
we can do this in a
it's not that easy but we can combine
genome information and genetic
information and we are trying to do this
right now
but uh we still need to to do some
research on that
uh
and now
using these genotypes or this
those genotypes i'm going to talking
about how to phase and how to map
this multiple alleles it does this
multiple dosages in the context of a
complex polyploid or any employed level
at all
of course we have computational
computational limitations
but the model works for any point level
uh and there you go
the first thing we need to model when
you're imagining a transmission of
alleles
is how the gametes are formed
here i'm doing a simplification
and i'm choosing not to
assess the double reduction as i said to
you which is
a gamete that contains the same
homologue in the
in the
in the gambit right
uh
and here we are just considering
bivalent parents or bevel and parents
uh
so we can have this first divalent
parent right a pairing
let's say one paired with six two five
and three four okay this is one
possibility
another possibility would be one six two
four
three five and so on we can have several
possibilities right
in this case we can have 15
possibilities right
but for any employed level you can have
this number of possibilities here right
oh by the way all these the derivation
of these formulas are in this
in this paper here okay i will share
this this will be in my github so you
can you can see
um
yeah so you have this formula here right
so for a tetraploid this is three for an
example this is 15 and for an octopoid
this is 70
7 0
so as you can see this is not linear
right this is the problem with with
polyploids if you add one
more homolog
the complexity is not linear it's not
not even
exponential is another
for it's another function but it is it
is an explosive function
and
how can you deal with this complexity so
as i said to you we have a bivalent
parent
a pairing
and then imagine we have this 15
possible
by valid pairings
and then we can model each one of these
pairings
using their recombination just like
lucky using the mindset of a back cross
right
so we will have
the recombinant gametes and the
non-recombinant
non-recombinant gametes we can model
using this matrix here this is a very
popular matrix in in in genetics
and what we can do is combine each one
of these matrices
using something we call a chronicle
product
and then uh
it's very interesting because you can do
this for any employed level and you have
a very simple formula
for any played level given one possible
configuration right and one possible in
one recombination fraction here but in
this possible configuration we call psi
right so here we have several size right
and then given one of this size
we can
uh have
this formula wholes right and l here is
the number of recombination recombinant
by valence we have
between this two loss i here
but of course this is for one
possible configuration
and what we can do instead of just using
one possible configuration since i know
all the possible configurations for any
ploid level
what i can do is to sum
over all possible configurations
and
uh given the the probability of each one
of these configurations
and here since i'm assuming that i have
an auto polyploid right
all these configurations beer here
you have the same probability and what i
can do is to sum over all possible this
is for an extra point 15 configurations
for one gamete
and if i sum
across all these configurations i will
have this formula here this is for one
gamete okay
and then i can feel this whole matrix
here and as you can see there's a
pattern in this matrix this is very
important and and you have this this
uh
function
and then
you can have a probability of having two
genotypes
unconditional to the configuration you
are assuming
if you have something that we call
segmental polyploidy which means that
some pairing are more likely than other
pairing situations you can
work on this using this probability here
but this is another conversation
anyway so if you have this probability
uh what you can do
is actually using standard likelihood
functions
to assess each one of the configurations
of phasing
are more likely so here i have two
situations right
i have big a big a
and two small a's big b and three small
b's in one possible configuration they
are in association here right
they are in the same homolog these two
in this case we have
also the same thing what you observe in
your data is the same thing you observe
two and one
and here you also observe two and one
the question is what is the
configuration between these two uh uh
dosages
and here we have the second
configuration
and if you have that probability you can
assemble you you can build a likelihood
function right you can maximize this
like likelihood function obtain the
recombination fraction you can just
compare them what's the most likely
configuration so this would be a very
easy way to do a a a a a phasing
with uh
combining multiple
markers right
uh and of course if you have this you
can view the map or you can try to infer
the inheritance just using this
situation here
but
because you have your recombination
between all possible
uh
markers in your population right
and then you can order you can group
then in chromosomes and you can have
your your your uh recombination fraction
and then you have a map
but
as you saw in in a previous it's like
there's a lot of noise in this situation
especially in exoplanets you it's very
difficult to distinguish between the
noise and the signal
and then using just the information of
two markers
is not enough to have a good map or to
have a good inheritance
study so
so what's what's the next step
so instead of just using
two markers we are going to use the
whole genome or the whole linkage group
to infer
the hypo the haplotype uh the the
phasing of these uh dosages right so
this is what you see in your data set
this is an example of an exoplanet right
it's just a piece of chromosome small
piece
seven markers right and i will have two
doses one those three doses and so on
this is the information what i want to
achieve is this information
i have the two doses and the two first
homologues the second those in the the
first homolog and so on i want to know
how these
doses are distributed
and if i know how they are distributed
in this five in the six homologs
i can have a real map so here i have
this is a real map this i think this is
chromosome number one the beginning of
chromosome number one of sweet potato
and then you can have
your possible your nucleotides here and
you can see how these nucleotides are
distributed in these homologs and here
we have the distance the genetic
distance this is incentive organs right
in your
uh
in your map
so the map
in a
polyploid is not just this is striped
with several markers but it's also
the haplotypic configuration of this the
homologues
and the way we did this
using something we called hidden markov
models right
so uh a markovian property is something
that is very very important in genetics
and it's using
all across genetics it's a it's such an
important model
and it's a very simple concept but it's
very powerful
because
it deals with something we call
condition independence
which means that
if i know something that happens in the
previous
time
it's enough for my model because
the something that happens in the
previous time is also conditioned into
the something it happens the previous
previous time so this makes a chain
of course that here
in in the chromosomes you can ask oh
but this is not true because the
chromosomes they have the
three-dimensional structure and you can
have interactions that's true
but
as genetics shows this is a very very
good way to model a chromosome
uh and it's very powerful there are
several papers showing that this is this
is very powerful
and then i choose this
option to model the polyploid genome
and i convert that
unconditional probability you saw in
this in that picture in that slide with
several matrices
into a conditional probability so what's
the probability of observing a certain
genotype
right
in a specific time or is in a specific
position in the genome given the
previous position
and this is in function of the
recombination fraction of course
deploy the level and the number of
recombinant events
we observed
between these two positions
and what you can do here
is actually combine this
in a way we call backward and forward
algorithm it's a i don't have time to
explain here if you want to understand
this there's these two publications here
this publication here is awesome it's
from from from a group in birmingham in
in england
uh and this is a this publication from
our group
and
and what we do with the hidden markov
model and why is hidden this is the the
thing that the markovian property tells
you that you have a conditional
independence
but why it's this this this our model is
hidden
and the short answer is because we can't
access the true genotype
we just assess the dosages
and the dojis are not the true genotypes
the true genotypes are the homologues
right the true genotypes are the third
in the tetraploid are the 36 states
and i'm going to show you here the 36
states so what we observe
in a specific individual imagine we have
a cross between two
uh parents and these are the
configurations of these dosages uh one
dose in one parent one those in the
other parent to those in the other
parent to those and the other parent and
so on okay and this is the true
configuration
and for a given individual
i have in a population in a by parental
cross like okay so this is a trio have
two parents and one of spring
for a specific individual i observe one
dose one dogs one those three doses one
those and so on
there's a way that i don't have time to
explain here but to map
these
dosages given a specific
phasing configuration here in the
parents
okay so for the true configuration
for the true configuration the parenting
this
uh red
dots here
they are the states that we should visit
meaning that
i know this is one right what are these
states that could generate this one and
these states are this
this
red states here
right so this given this possible this
configuration here
same thing for the the the the this case
here we have two doors in both parents
but i observed one dose
for that marker
in in the offspring in this specific
individual
what are the
the states that i need to visit
are these states here
and the
the the nice thing about this hidden
markov models we've if you something's
called something we call baum and welch
algorithm which is a special case of of
expectation maximization algorithm
we can maximize
this likelihood function and what is
going to happen
is that we are going to trace the most
likely path
in this
very complex trellis here and this is
what it's going to do this is real okay
so
in the zero interaction here i have all
possibly states when i go through my em
okay for these 15 markers for this
specific individual imagine that this is
this is uh something that that
the algorithm is doing for all
individuals in my population
i can build the haplotype using the
combination of these multiple markers
okay
so here
for this individual the data set that i
have just won those but when i use the
hidden markov model this is not not
one of those anymore this is a d from
one parent and gh for the other parents
it's much much more informative
and then but how i can how this is
possible because i'm combining
information of multiple markers using
this hidden record model
and as i said all the explanation all
the derivations all the formulas the em
are in in that paper
uh and if you can discuss because
sometimes there's some some trick points
in that paper it took me a long time
just to figure out how to represent this
mathematically
uh
and we can discuss just send me an email
we can discuss this but the most
important thing here is that we can see
the we have these two
these two gametes here a d g h and then
in a point here
it changes right
why it changes
because there's a crossing over and then
i know exactly what was the crossing
over it was between g and f because they
are different here you can see
right
and using this
type of of uh uh
algorithm
we apply this in a in a experimental
population
this is a beautiful population with a
beautiful data set right and kudos
to body or cool or lokulu
uh
i've never worked with such a great data
set
and also we have two very very nice
reference genomes deep white genomes we
have these two parents bury garden
tanzania bergaard
it's a
it's a
orange flesh sweet potato
a high beta carotene a very sweet um
uh low resistance to to to nematodes and
something in
another uh
things and here we have tanzania
tanzania is from of course tanzania
and then uh
low beta carotene but very resistant and
we have a a biparent population
and this is just a beautiful picture
and i said to mark soros this morning
that i'm going to show this picture this
is a white parental cross
can you imagine this is they're all
full sieves they have the same
parents and they're so different this is
the beauty of the the the exoplanet you
know
and if if you see the i i don't have the
the the picture of the the leaves but
you have the variations between this
heart form
in this other another form in the
population as well so it you are you you
really can see the genetics working with
your eyes here it's it's such a
beautiful population
and um
what we did here is apply our two point
algorithm here
and then we could
uh reconstruct out the link all the
linkage groups and as you can see here
this is very consistent
this is beautiful uh
linkage groups right
um in a linkage group and this is
recombination fraction right so in
recombination fraction you you expect
that you have uh
closer markers
in an order recombination fraction you
have markers that are closed in the in
the in the
in the diagonal here the markers that
are far away in in the corner of the
matrix and this is exactly what you
observe here
and this is uh about
30 000 markers right
and then using this in the the
the hmm algorithm we could build this
map so this is the map this in this
publication here
and i'm going to zoom in one of these
linkage groups and we have 15 linkage
groups here
uh and i'm going to zoom in the first
linkage group so we can
i can show you
the components of this this map
here we have the map as we know so this
is what we will be representing is just
have a deployed map is just this and of
course you can anchor this map in
reference genomes here we have
the thrift diploid genome and here we
have the triloba genome as you can see
we have some rearrangements here
and we discussed this in the paper but
most of the genome is very very
consistent as you can see
here and here we have the configuration
of both parents
bureaucrat and tanzania right and here
we have we have something called
genotypic information content
which is
how much you can distinguish between
haplotypes here as you can see we have
the yellow here a little bit lower
because these two
first parts here between e and f
they are very similar right but here
they are different so you can
distinguish between or among all these
haplotypes
so we have the haplotypes of our parents
beautiful
but the most important thing
is to reconstruct the haplotypes in the
offspring why
because we want to associate it as
haplotypes with phenotypes right
and of course you know deploy this you
can if you have such a
a dense genome
and you you have such beautiful
reconstructed uh maps and
so it's it's
you can trust this but
in your data set right and even you you
need to do some filtering of course but
in a polyploid the filtering
is much heavier and if you want to use
your data set in the maximum
what you need to do is actually to use
our hidden markov model or not our the
hidden recon model or some way to
combine the information in the whole
population
and you can reconstruct the haplotypes
of each one of individuals in your
offspring
so
here
what is this graphic here
here we have
all the possible eight haplotypes
in our pop in one individual you know in
a tetraploid potato right this is real
data sets okay if you look in this
individual this is public you can do
redo the analysis you find exactly the
same thing here
if you don't use
the hidden markov model
what you see is something like this
and these are the possible eight
homologues
inherited by this individual from two
parents i know the homologs in their
parents a b c and d
uh
e f g and h
and here for this first part
this individual inherited
a
inherited
b with some noise here
okay
inherited for this part inherited
c
and for this part inherited d and the
same for the other parents here right
and these points here will be the
recombination points but you have a lot
of noise not a lot but you have noise
here
and when you use the hidden markov model
what it does is exactly this
it cleans
the the data set because it uses the
information
of all the the the markers
and what you can do is to use a prior
probability so if you have markers that
are less likely to be called
correctly you can inform these two
hidden record model using that
probability distribution i discussed
some slides ago okay so if you inform
that or even if you form a global
warehouse the hidden micro model adjusts
the the the history of the whole
chromosome okay
you can say oh this is just a little bit
of improvement but
in sweet potato look
this is a very very noise
individual and this is also again a real
individual in our sweet potato map
when he used that that type of uh
the type of uh strategy
what you do is this
you still have some inconsistencies but
it's much better than this right
and of course if you use this you
deflate the map because if you use
something like this to construct your
map it will count a lot of
recombinations that are not true right
and then you use the hidden markov model
you deflate your map because you're
counting just the true recombination
fractions okay
so this is the power of this this
multilocus analysis
and again this is developed for any
point level
and of course
sometimes it's very beautiful to have
all this this graphics and statistics
but
you need a software to apply this and we
we have this software
it's an air package to construct these
maps
uh it's in the it's a third version now
and uh
we are very glad that we have a lot of
downloads this package and we are
constantly trying to improve this
package
and if you guys use just and you find
bugs or if you want something new new in
the package some new features just send
me an email actually send an email to
gabriel and then he'll do that
okay which is the my the postdoc is
working here with us
but anyway this is matt paulie
and we can do all these analysis in that
poly
and this is the
the output of one of the the maps of our
maps we have a
shiny app where you can navigate in your
map
and
today is much more developed and i will
show you another program that we also
developed to do this but you can you can
choose the windows
of your of your map
and you can check possible haplotypes
and yeah anyway this is the this is the
map but
in polyploids
uh it's very interesting if you could
understand the meiotic behavior or the
meiotic landscape
of your species
what do i mean about that this
you need to know
there's the the points of recombinations
and how the haplotypes
were
combined or
paired
in your meiosis and using this strategy
you can do this
so here
we have the same graphic that i was
showing you
uh in the in some slides ago
for in so this is one individual in our
by parental population and i'm just
studying the meiosis in this one
individual actually i'm studying the
meiosis in the parents of the individual
in the gametes they were formed to form
this individual right
here we have the centromeric region
which we we assess using the
diploid genome in hopefully in four or
six months six months we have the
exoplanet genome we are working on that
and
and here you have the points of
recombination right
so here i have homolog a recombination
with homolog b
uh homolog e recombination with c and
the whole chromosome and homo homo f so
i can't say that this was the
configuration i have my centromere here
and the
recombination points over here
in the other parents in the tanzania
parent
i had
my homolog k
a recombination with h and then h
recombined with l and l recombined with
i and so on so
this is very weird because we have
multiple recombinations and we actually
form a chain of recombinations and if
you have a chain of recombinations the
only way to to get this chain
is through something we call a
multivalent formation you remember in
these slides that i said we have a valid
formation and a multivalent formation
and this is an evidence of a multivalent
formation and in this case we have an
exaval information
meaning that
each arm of the chromosomes combine to
other arm of the chromosomes in
exchanges in a changed pieces
you see here the only arms that
do not exchange the pieces are these two
arms
and then
here as you can see if you don't have
a oops yeah this is good uh yeah uh yeah
so here you have your the result of this
meiosis
and here as you can see
for the first three game three homologs
here you just have two colors right
because we just have by valence
but in this case we can have three
colors
why
because we have multi so the multivalent
formation
is one more source of variability in
your inner inner uh
individual right
so and this is very important to know
and we assess all the individuals and
this is the distribution in sweet potato
these are probably
by valence right the the the
uh
light greens and lighter greens right
and these other ones here they're
usually probably
uh tetravalents exo valence penta
balance
and so on but as you can see it's mostly
by valence right
anyway
so this is one very important thing we
have here
uh and this is not using
cytological techniques this is very
important because
this is this uh
fish techniques or gish techniques
there's very
labor
intense to do you know and here's is not
as exact it's not as the same thing but
it's like a
shadow of that we can obtain in a
cytogenetic studies
another very very important thing is to
assess if
the the the
homologs
if there's some preferentiality in the
pairing of these homologs
and we can we also can assess this using
our probabilities our actually our or
the probability of of our homologs
and here
the the dashed line
is uh
what you expect
in a
in a in a
random pairing
and here we have all possible
combinations of our homologs these are
our
by valence
and here as you can see we just have one
possible configuration that is more
likely here
but actually we have the reciprocal and
we notice that this is something just in
this data set it's something probably
this is something is previous here but
what we can say that in terms of
segregation
sweet potato is vastly auto polyploid
not in terms of origin
we are not on that because this is just
how the
homologs are combining the terms of
origin we need on other studies but in
terms of recombination in terms of
pairing is the same thing
so what we do here is just to have this
uh um
uh uh haplotypes reconstructed and what
why we do this is to connect with
phenotypes right
i don't have the time and this is not uh
we are starting to work
uh more deeper in the genotype in this
phenotypes now here
uh but still we have
uh several papers with other with our
collaborators about phenotypes as i said
it will be this will publicly you can
look into these papers but we used all
these uh technologies i showed you here
to
to to
publish in this paper so these are sweet
potato papers and these are potato
papers
uh
with our collaborators from africa and
here in united states as well
and this is the most important paper
which proposes the method to do this
it's a very nice paper so we published
uh in 2020
and now
the next step we are doing here
is just not using two populations but
using multiple interconnected
populations this is the first i see here
that
yeah almost 15 minutes yeah i think i'm
good
and here what we are doing is just
instead of using two populations we are
using multiple interconnected
populations meaning that some parents
are shared between populations
and you can reconstruct the genotypes
and and tell and you cannot you can have
the mosaic of
uh uh haplotypes for each individual it
is multiple
population
uh uh thing right like a diallio you
have
actually you we're working in an eight
eight eight by eight dialer now
eight by eight dialect with
exoplanets so can you imagine how many
algos we can have in this
in in this in this scenario so and we
are working on that
so as you can see here we have the
pieces green pieces are from this uh uh
species here with nilka logo is another
african
uh cultivar
and then we can trace back
in the same way we did in the biparental
right and this is the map and just
instead of having just two homologues we
have multiple
uh homology groups here
instead here we have just three because
these three populations we have this
just three
parents but
in in further studies we have much more
um and i think i i'm going to my left oh
yeah it's not the last slide but this is
the
one of the lesser slides and of course
we are trying to implement friendly
tools because as you can imagine these
analysis are very very
time consuming you need a lot of
computational power to do this but we
are trying to to
have this user-friendly tools we had
just submitted a paper
for this tool here is a graphical tool
it doesn't do any analysis but you can
put all your results here you can
navigate your chromosomes you can
navigate your qtl peaks we are going to
uh
put another uh
folder here with genomic selection and
probably
uh uh g walls and then you can connect
with your genome this is something that
is just a graphical
a nice thing to have right
and uh so just perspectives
so
and uh as moira said we just got a usda
nifa uh
grant approved in the beginning of this
year
and now the next step is actually to try
to bridge this gap we have
between this complex genetics of
polyploids
in practical situations that's i'm going
to do
everything
that i can do to try to bridge this gap
i know this is very difficult
and uh
the way i'm trying to do this is to try
to build user-friendly tools not just to
have these fancy algorithms and just
you and you can't have a user-friendly
tool right and and my intent what i want
to do with this is
help readers make this inform the
decisions you know based on their data
sets
and i i know i'm i'm i'm i'm not a
breeder but one of the things that i'm
doing right now is to communicate with a
lot of breeders i'm going to the field
here with craig yancho
and at least once or
no not once or
every
two weeks and go to the food and discuss
with breeders what they need and and
what would be the best way to to do this
and uh
and you know we hunt we want to provide
based on this
architecture we have
we have a tool to help readers to select
individuals to
meeting strategies or breeding
strategies using simulations of course
if you have the model you can do forward
simulations
and this is very important because this
is very
crop specific
as you see
as you saw as
sweet potato is an auto polyploid and i
know that for instance brachiaria is not
an auto polyploid it's a segmental
polyploid so maybe this strategy is
different
so this is so
crop specific some plants are more
resilient some some plants are more
recalcitrant
it's very difficult to have a single
way to deal with those plants and i
would say that i can't i can
have my my overarching objective
is to use this technology
and use this inheritance
in this inferior interference of this
genomic inheritance
or this haplotype transmission
through dispatch release to elucidate
the genetic relationships between these
complex individuals using this in a qtl
scenario
and with that i'm i'm open to questions
here there's some collaborators
and i have so many collaborators
and i'm very grateful to work with these
guys
and here i have my former supervisor
augusto
the post doctor is helping me a lot
gabrielle here we have craig and here we
have zoebank and here you have gilliam
and then this is a nice picture you took
in in africa
several years ago and that's it thank
you
for listening my presentation and i'm
open to questions
thank you marcelo
i hope i'm
yeah
okay um are there any questions from the
audience first some references
i'll also look at chat
yeah oh the chat of course
um okay ed made a comment so cool to see
the multivalence beautiful yeah it's
nice i love it yeah
marcelo i was kind of wondering how
important
you know when you do some of that
initial ordering and trying to create
linkage maps
uh how important is the physical genome
or can it be the physical genome and how
important
are you know
is the ordering you know is it if it's
ten percent wrong
uh how big a problem is that or
yeah yeah you know computation i mean i
know you could drive everything totally
without a physical genome but i'm sure
it's got to save computational resources
if you have some hypothesis
exactly that's a very very good point
and since this was like a pilot project
what we did we did both ways right
and we
so and we don't have the
the actual gene exoplanet you know we
are working in the exoplanet now so
these are reference genomes they are
diploids
and what we did
was to build the dino order
and what we observed is that in terms of
phasing
it's not that a problem because
when you switch a face we are switching
the recombination counts
and you have a wrong phase your mate
your map inflates
crazily it's like you have a huge
inflation you know so you can see that's
not the phase is not correct
so this is one thing
of course the local ordering
is not that good i i have the graphics
and i i can show you in our conversation
this this afternoon
and then but they are very consistent
with the genome you know but you can see
huge rearrangements between the diploid
and the hexaploid genomes
and what i did
was to
manually cut these pieces
right
computed the likelihood of
our de novo order in the likelihood of
the general based order and
all the time
the likelihood of the genome was much
better
and the net was much smaller okay so
answering your question is very
important
it does help reduce the the problem
space yes yes and if you combine both
and if you combine both
you can correct your genotypes much
better yeah
yeah but yeah the fact that you're the
beauty of you being able to phase
there's a you know is lovely to see that
yes
it is
i've also noticed that at least when
we've talked to our breeders about the
alfalfa and the blueberry
the genetic map versus the
physical map
the
appearance of the centromeres are
extremely clear
because they don't change in genetic
distance but they do
in physical distance so that's been very
helpful for us to decide where markers
don't need to be and where we can read
distribute markers so we did the same
but have you need to have a good
reference genome i think that's that's
very helpful yeah
yeah exactly it and and uh
and the problem with the sweet potato is
that the centromere is all over the
place you know it's not like a
metacentromeric species
and then you sometimes you have like an
acro telomere
and then you have in the in the closer
the telomere the same from here
so but still we can observe the same in
sweet potato this is the beauty of the
map versus the genome and also there's a
function
in in map poly that
draws that that's that
comparison yeah yeah that's been very
helpful to communicate carb readers
um any questions from the audience here
okay well thank you so much marcelo for
your talk today i'm sorry we couldn't
have you here in person
um would have been very nice but um i
really enjoyed your talk and i'm glad
you started with the most difficult
species sweet potato
it makes everything you do in blueberry
and alfalfa looks super easy
all right well thank you so much thank
you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu